[Music]
nico this is in your key dude
it is start with me what core are you
playing a chord
a modified d minor
i put my mic at my instrument
my microphone's not set up
all right all right everybody stop
stop jerking around guys this is serious
we got things to talk about
smiling we got podcasts to pot about
yeah we got casts to cast um i think
it's clear that nick is the real
vagabond in this group given that he's
both playing mandolin
and a street accordion at the same time
it's not like
[Music]
talk about the street recording for a
second here and also can we can i drone
it for a moment yeah dude so it's a it's
called a shruti box
and it's oh excuse me a shruti box a
shruti box a dwight fruit box you are
shrewdy
that's the one for the books um
all right not to be confused with you
i'm holding the treaty box you want me
to start playing right now don't talk
about it until
one of the notes is open or else you're
going to pump air into nothing and it'll
pop it
so you got to make sure you so this is
like an accordion it's an eastern
instrument used in turkey and
i think like asia minor a lot but it's
like a really old
old instrument and it basically creates
an acoustic drone
like almost a synth drone yeah no it's
it's very
calming it's very peaceful it's used in
medicine a lot like
yoga and healing and meditation okay i
can see that
so so you're going to want to select
your root note i did i feel like the
tones like resonate with my nerves
you know and like it hits you like on a
deep level
with your bones yeah and you kind of
pump it like a like you want to pump it
before
the breath is over if that makes it all
interesting yeah so like so
start with a nice big one start with a
nice big breath and just
slowly slowly like pump it yeah
wait where's the noise coming from is it
the little holes in the outside yeah so
point the mics
point the mic uh on the outside here
yeah there you go and now
yeah and now open it up before in the
sands of time
there was a man looking for the perfect
sound so this is like you just roll up
in the desert and it's like the
post-apocalypse you know
and like the wind whipped hard on his
chiseled face
his skin like leather we should consider
making our own music for corridor videos
sometime
yeah right yeah
have you guys ever thought about making
a band called like the the stay here
the stay here and don't move the place
of last
the obtain the maintain that's that's a
good band name i mean
the how about the high tower the high
tower
jacob hit you with a d minor all right
here we go
let me get this capo off of here
my confidence when it comes to musical
abilities are so low red you can play
this one
you definitely can play the shootie box
i should probably play the shruti bucks
is it the shootie box like shoot him up
shruti like a short
like a white tree
true yeah moody atmospheric sound
and podcast listeners today were not
prepared for the ultimate chill session
welcome guys if you're still awake at
this point
i that's uh nick where did you find that
thing man
i you even learn about that yeah where
does one discover an instrument of this
nature
um there's a i went down a rabbit hole
of turkish folk music
you found this in a rabbit hole yes
i went down like a youtube rabbit hole
of turkish folk music
there's like some channel that i can't
even read the name of i literally can't
read it
i don't know but
it's a really cool music and there's
some lady in this jam session playing
one of these things and i was just like
dang that's really cool
like what is this acoustic synth
so yeah i looked it up and then like uh
you
you can order them online so not amazon
though but
not on amazon okay it's made in like
freaking i mean i love the the
tag on it it's like made in some random
country like timbuk kumar sardar and
brothers
sons of kagan sardar they're the ones
you want
coggins are the are the guys
for when you're looking for analog synth
notes consider no one else but cog and
sarder
honestly you can reach them at mono jkr
sardar
dude shout out sardar brothers
scott i just got a free shout out i'm
gonna level up
like in a couple years when i can afford
it like they have these like
like this times four where it's just
like you get like four octaves
does it still come in a briefcase though
i hope so it's kind of like a big
briefcase it's like this because
one of the coolest things about that
would be the ability to walk with it
anywhere and then you open
it and then like three more accordions
russian accordions yeah and they're all
different octaves
i think the goal is eventually that like
we all can bring our musical instruments
on the one wheel and go on like a desert
ride where we're just like
going through the desert playing i have
to get a little mini hand pan they make
those by the way like little tiny ones
like i mean they're still like 18 inches
across or something yeah 18 inches
that's
like a pizza that's still pretty big
yeah it's enough to just have on a
little still pretty much
kind of a little pizza pan yeah you hold
on your hand
pizza pan what's the diameter of this
one 21 inches
she's about so the mini one is three
inches shorter
well it's also shallower just you know
volume i guess nico did you
did you introduce your new daughter to
us
sorry milo now you're a second child
yeah we did a little bit in the last
episode um okay
but i've gotten a lot better volatility
at like playing this because i've
started like figure out where the chords
are
and you know just the techniques to make
it sound good stainless steel is a
little bit different than like
other stuff i actually got a little
tripod to set it on and like it's so
resonant that it actually doesn't
quite sound that great it's like it like
drowns itself
like whoa
so if you stand too close to it and move
it vibrates
yeah it actually does
like yeah you're right uh and this one
has a little note on the bottom too
which is really cool
your other one didn't have that right my
other one did not have that
so i have a really big scale sorry
[Music]
yeah yeah you should do the sound we
should do a sound of music remake with
that thing
yes always down i've never seen that
movie but
let's go you've never seen that movie i
haven't seen the sound of music
that's it it's a classic man you should
watch it i know i like to see it
yeah don't they kill hitler at the end
of it i think so
[Music]
sound of music is great and it's got a
bunch of really good songs to it and
it's really well shot
and it's it gets written off as like a
cheesy old movie but it's actually
really
really well done it's did you guys ever
see that movie did you see the movie bed
knobs and broomsticks do you remember
that movie
uh yes isn't that with like the
teleporting bed or that that could fly
yeah well yeah yeah something like that
knobs
yeah okay fair enough so i watched the
movie a whole bunch i was really into it
mainly for
the last thing it's kind of like a fall
up to mary poppins so they had like the
whole like live characters against
cartoons
right yeah and uh did they also use that
crazy like special
patented crystal form and what's that
sulfur crystal who's the actress from
murder she wrote
i don't know she's dead well she was in
it too okay uh but
sorry that was a joke on murder hey i
don't even get murdered
oh i see what you mean she might still
be alive
uh anyways the reason i bring that up is
i don't tell you if you remember this
friend so she's a witch she's like a
benevolent witch
and you know she's taking all these
different lands and they're going to do
all these different crazy things
but at the end it's it's set in britain
during world war ii
and the germans invade their town and so
they go
down to the local history museum and
reanimate all the
suits of armor so that there's
reanimated armor fighting nazis
what yeah they're like shooting them
with machine guns and like
i've never heard of this yeah it's like
you know to like
five-year-old niko this is the coolest
thing ever i mean it's still pretty dang
cool but
you know you watched a lot of really old
movies as a kid you brought up
freaking flubber the old original
flubber movie that i didn't even know
existed
like the one with original williams
yeah the black and white one yeah the
black and white didn't she shoot that
episode of visual effects artist reactor
was that
i didn't shoot that one um wow i didn't
know if flubber had a
pre a pre-flubber you didn't know yeah
whoa okay that's not what i meant
you know we can't really show people
yeah no it's not good to show videos
it's not good to watch videos during
this podcast because no one else can
was it cg or stop-motion not even some
videos it's like a bunch of like crazy
puppetry to make like
invisible suits of armor just like
walking through can you just put a
person in the suit of armor and look at
this they even got they got horses they
got people mounted on like floating
horses
they're like we promise there's no
actual people in there
anytime there's sci-fi creations
fighting nazis i mean you pretty much
have a home run of a piece right there
there's no special effects
don't show me don't there's no visual
effects let's this oh they even made a
movie
well then how did they do that that's
still a magic trick we could talk about
that tomorrow
shooting these nights down with their
mounted machine guns and these kids like
wow oh dude this is like goony status
man
this is like everything i'm about
reanimated knights like
imagine if harry potter took place in
world war ii and it's wizards versus
like
german soldiers like how cool is that
that sounds pretty sweet yeah it's
overdue
but not some broomsticks hey are we ever
gonna do tactical wizards
um yeah yeah i'm working on it we were
just talking about that what are you
talking about earlier today oh okay
should i stop talking about it no no
let's talk about it like there's nothing
wrong with talking about an idea because
you designed your whole freaking
d son of a dungeon character after like
what you hope
to be like a tactical wizard like
imagine like just the most like kitted
out wizard that's like
an assassin exactly yeah because like
nobody
you know either if you have wizard stuff
and magic stuff it's either harry potter
or it's marvel you don't really have
anything else like there's no
good solid medieval fantasy wizard stuff
that's like got the modern action movie
approach or feel to it it's always goofy
or it's always kid oriented
i mean there's the king arthur does that
kind of really merlin is like the
new the new the what's the guy the guy
right
was it or was it is that nothing in the
different ones legends
i've been to merlin's grave by the way
why the real murderer
the real merlin has a real grave i
didn't know merlin was real dude
yeah you're blowing my mind right now
yeah it's this rock like this old like
it's a rock it's what was it like
there's these like monoliths
oh yeah remember the gauls used to have
their like their lists or whatever
yeah so there's like something like that
that's like ancient the stella esteli
yeah i'm not sure yeah yeah where where
in france is this
um i think it's in like central southern
france
something like that it's kind of it's in
the forest where the king arthur legends
are supposed to have taken place
i thought which is important in england
no it took place in france
oh yeah so they went from
england to gaul to look for the holy
grail
the gall of them maybe i don't know like
that they went to jerusalem or uh that's
indiana jones sorry i'm getting it mixed
up
yeah i think when they got down to
jerusalem they found these crystal
skulls
yeah about 18 miles west of ren the
force of
pamphon is all that remains of the vast
forest that covered the ancient
inland brittany aka argoat
has it that the 25 square miles of
woodland is also the location of
mythical process the forest of king
arthur
where was this place near there's a lot
of granulation in france
i don't know sherwood forest is my
arthur
i'm a sherwood boy okay okay it isn't
sure what uh
isn't that the other guy robin hood oh
shoot
yeah you're right
where's our resident englishman scott
when you need to clarify some of this
yeah so back to tactical wizards i
suppose though so like
the the idea here is like to do a
tactical fight scene but it's with
wizards using their magic so like
instead of like
a flashbang or like say you know like uh
if you played rainbow six you remember
like the door breaches right where you
put the charge on the door you can blow
the door in
so imagine instead the magical
equivalent that is like
the soldiers are ready to breach you
have all your like guards in there with
their crossbows
and then the wizard comes up takes out
like a a bucket of blood
paints a rune on the door and sets backs
there's an incantation the door
shatters and the piece is flying but
then they freeze in the air soldiers run
into the room
and then the the wizard whispers one
more word and then the pieces of the
door go
and they come back and reform the door
you know like
you're doing a door breech but with
magic you know you know
i know a program that could simulate
that
yeah that's like it's real dnd harry
yeah it's real dmd it's basically all
the program harry
all the cool action scenes you imagine
when you play d and d
but actually directed and executed as an
authentic
we should just call it real d and d or
something like that instead of tactical
wizards because tactical wizards makes
it sound
like it's guys in wizards costumes as
swot
yeah i mean i mean that was kind of the
idea what i'm imagining
well yeah but i'm talking about like
modern dimes with m4s
and swat gear but they just have beards
kind of yeah where does the wizardry
come in i mean like but i wouldn't put
in like you know
rubber boots and kevlar vest but they'd
still have like the modern equivalent of
that you know
oh so it's it's taking place in modern
times no it's taking place
in a time where people have magic and
can make anything they want so
it's like what would your high-end
adventure garb look like you know you're
not going to be some scrub running
around with a potato sack on your feet
of course but i'm saying like really
nice hand leather
yeah aesthetically is it like medieval
fantasy or is it
modern it's medieval fantasy but taking
cues from the practicality of modern
okay so they're wearing
would be wearing like classic metal
armor rather than kevlar
right it sounds very shrek to me you
know how they have like the knights like
doing like like doing a traffic stop and
stuff
like like the fairies and stuff i mean
any like or you know lord of the rings
is a decent like reference of like the
high-end elves and rangers like kind of
what they're wearing there but like just
pare down the fantasy imagery a little
bit and like
step it towards practicality step it
towards like actual like
you know what did the the king's best
soldiers wear you know like in real life
in in you know the medieval times like
or you know right at the beginning of
the renaissance like what's
the pinnacle of technology and skill and
craftsmanship
for combat you know suits and weapons
like that's kind of what we're looking
at
can we thread can situational comedy or
does it have to be like super serious
and dramatic and actiony the whole time
it's not necessarily super serious but
it needs to take itself seriously
yeah sure right but so like the office
takes itself seriously
no it doesn't so like what is the
medieval it kind of does
no the actors take it seriously but the
show yeah
that's okay yeah that's what i guess
that's what i meant i mean we also did
we did this kind of wizard cops
yeah which is no not really wait is that
the movie bright
dude i remember so i remember when we
made wizard cops and we were trying to
get a movie off the ground and we're
like there's so much more to explore
with wizard cops
and like we start talking to various
like companies about it they're like
have you heard of this thing called
bright
and we're like no and they're like it's
kind of wizard cops
so yeah and it turned out it was it was
straight up wizard from cup
straight up wizard cops wizard cops came
out for what do you mean it was straight
up wizard cups like is there actually a
correlation
it's it's almost like the less funny
version of wizard cops like straight up
it's like
wizards on the beat doing their police
jobs in a city that happens to have
magic and people all just trying to make
it work
yeah just like we were live yeah
yeah we're not we're not suggesting they
stole it from us we're not
we're just saying you know a lot of
people haven't said maybe maybe
yeah before he got heavily cancelled
yeah
i mean don't you guys like know him and
a lot of the same people
i mean he was in the he was like around
the circles of people that we knew
but yeah he uh he had a lot of
allegations come out against them from
people who are
my friends which is very strange to be
so close to such a thing
yeah but you know kudos to the women for
coming forward and saying something yeah
it sounded like he was a real piece of
work
hey guys brandi o'daniel back with
another
amazing sponsor of today's podcast
this one you may have heard before
that's right storyblocks
why because storyblocks is the complete
solution
for all of your stock asset needs they
are the one-stop shop
the cat's pajamas the bee's knees the
best
in the biz that's right storybox has a
virtually
unlimited library of high quality
royalty-free assets
everything from video b-roll after
effects templates
music sound effects motion graphics and
more
they've got what you need and they're
constantly updating the site so
if you ever need to go back to something
out of their virtually unlimited library
it's gonna also continue to be updated
with their unlimited all access plan
you can download as much from the site
whenever you want and use it in whatever
kind of content you want that's right
it's completely royalty free
and if you're a creator working with an
even larger team consider talking to
your team leader about
an enterprise license with storyblocks
now as you know we use storyblocks all
the time around here it's one of the
greatest
tools that we have in our production
resource
kit and if you're looking to add another
tool to your toolkit
consider a subscription with storyblocks
just head on over to storybox.com
quartercast to get started that's
storyblocks.com
corridor cast now back to the podcast
not to change the subject too abruptly
but
i want to talk about attack on titan yes
what do you want to talk about ren
hey guys my name is ren and um i
like attack on titan and i think it's
kind of cool
um christian and nico how caught up are
you guys i'm about
three episodes back three episodes the
most recent one okay
um no but for me it doesn't matter it's
fine i will spoil it i'm not gonna spoil
it
wait are you are you caught up
um i think i may have just caved
caved to what i started reading the
manga oh really i
i had i can't wake i cannot wait week to
week
to find out what happens next when they
leave us on such
cliffhangers you're like a kid coming
out to his parents right now you're like
mom
dad i started reading the main
canon of the attack on titan series and
i
i don't care what anyone thinks i i need
to be my own person
well there is we accept you there is a
slight reason behind it and i think it's
because i'm going to be making an attack
on titan
video yeah
i'm really digging the newest seasons
opening intro
yeah i find myself liking it more and
more like i used to skip it and now i'm
kind of just like i'm just going to
watch the intro i usually skip this but
no
no i uh so the idea behind this video
is that how big are titans from attack
on titan they look
huge especially like the colossal titan
it looks like a literal skyscraper
but it's a 50 meter titan so it's or 55
45 somewhere in that range it's
like 150 feet 160 feet which
isn't really that tall like a regular
like eight story
building in downtown is as tall as the
colossal titan yeah not that tall
just your average eight-story building
but if i was to put the colossal titan
on top of one of the skyscrapers in la
it would look wrong and out of place
because the skyscrapers would dwarf the
colossal titan
it would be really interesting to see
like how big the wall is too like the
inner wall
yeah because that's also something where
it's like in the
in the show that looks so huge compared
to the rest of the city
yeah it's like they could never build
that they could never do that but like
could they i mean the premise of how
they built those walls
is a little complicated it involves like
basically cementing 10 million people
into a wall
what totes yeah anyway
wait wait wait wait great wall style
yeah they made a wall
out of dead bodies and cement it's
called the great wall kind of
kind of
basically some people got turned into
some really big titans and then those
titans got really hard
whoa titan wall yeah so they made a wall
themselves kind of a spoiler that's kind
of i'm not gonna say more
they made a wall to prevent themselves
from titans with dead titans
these bonuses actually there's more
going on to it than that okay all right
all right
sounds like we're getting into spoiler
alert we're getting deep into the story
there
but no so it's like i i would love to be
able to i don't know part of me was
really inspired inspired by the
character creator video for handsome
squidward that we did recently
and nico and i had a moment where we
were talking about wait a minute we can
make titans
because i think it all has to do with
the fact that they they have no
genitalia
so it's like and neither do the
character creator models when you make
them
and so you can totally just like make a
naked person and it's a titan and you
just scale them up to be big
make their like facial proportions kind
of weird um
carmichael photoshopping on their face
facial expressions
extra teeth yeah yeah lots of extra
teeth just make them weird
because that's the weird thing about
attack on titan is that the titans
are just weird they are just straight up
really weird unless you unless we're
talking about like the main the cool
titans the ones that like
are transforming titans those are all
cool can you do
like uh anime like
graphic over the top of them not a
graphic but an anime texture over the
top of them so they kind of
shake it off like cell shading you could
but that'd be really hard oh i mean not
actually i don't know if it's hard i
just don't want to i want to make these
things look realistic
like really we do not choose to do
things because they are
hard nico we that should be no reason
not to do something
in this decade yeah
you should make the titans the crew
members
like just for the sake of entertainment
i think that would be serious to see
like
you is like a titan i mean that's not a
bad idea
i i've always wanted to see a naked 150
foot tall
precisely yeah i didn't resign that idea
actually until this season that
attack and titan is actually technically
a mech show
like almost every anime you know what
that's
that's really weird it's amazing you're
not wrong at all
and it still has nukes and all kinds of
stuff this is basically just
gundam wing but like bio bio gundam wing
flash yeah
it is straight up they just took a
really long way to get there and
arrive at that trope again yeah uh
so i i i mentioned this over the weekend
on twitter and
uh i've already had a couple artists
reach out to me willing to help
uh model some of these titans uh so far
we got aaron yeager the attack titan
we got uh one guy i'm talking to is
going to start designing the
female titan he's already got a base
layer of the beast titan
wow um i might just like download a
literal like
muscle skeleton 3d model for the
colossal titan because it's basically
just like what does a human look like
without skin
that's the colossal steam coming out
yeah just like some steam vents
have you ever been to the bodies exhibit
i have yeah
i don't see what a human looks like
without skin
that's creepy especially because they're
real bodies in that exhibit
right it's all real
it's not plastic it's just uh preserved
you guys remember that attack on titan
game that we were like really into back
in the day oh that that like indie one
that wasn't like an official technical
yeah which is still the best attack on
titan games do you know there's a second
one
about to come out and it's like way
better graphics it's not vr whoa
no not vr there are nuts though i mean
there's a vr mod there you can there's a
game on sidequest that's attack on titan
or the quest too i saw it i i probably
really dinky
i mean probably i don't know the motion
when you start like flying around like
that
you start dealing with dangerous motion
sickness territory
yeah that is potentially an issue
so something interesting about attack on
titan is you know so they have
all these crazy giants and they're like
in cities and they're fighting
and animating that is really really
difficult and you can usually tell when
there's going to be a big fight scene in
an episode when there's like
a lot of still shots before like when
people are talking in the camera like
cuts
to the table and it cuts to a window and
it cuts to
the feet you know it's like when it's
just like avoiding animation
that's because they're saving the
animation budget for like the fight
scenes but
in this season there's so much action
with big titans
that they actually went with the new
studio not because they could draw it
better but because the new studio
could do 3d models of the titans but
have them look hand drawn
so anytime there's a titan on screen now
it's a 3d model
but it's animated to look like it's hand
drawn yeah it's
it's pretty convincing yeah i think it's
pretty well done
yeah that's what i was saying you could
do that
yeah but then it looks like a cartoon i
know it'd probably look cooler as
a body just do the whole video well like
my point is like someone's already
doing that the show is doing it wait
wait wait wait what if the whole video
we turn into we do a cartoon texture on
it or an anime texture on it
and the whole video looks like it's
animated jake we would have to literally
invent a new
uh way of doing computer visual science
we choose to go to the european forum
knowing that it is hard we choose to go
for four things another thing going to
the moon
is nothing ren's about to put a 360
camera
sorry 180 camera on a falcon yes
can we talk we haven't talked about that
well that was a good segue yeah good
segue nick
it hasn't happened yet so i've been
avoiding telling anyone about that
um but yeah so we've had so okay first
off
today is the launch date of the insta360
go 2
which is kind of my favorite camera
right it's your go-to camera it's my
go-to
camera not sponsored yeah this is not
sponsored right now joke on his own by
the way
that was totally independent of our the
joke
actually nick the joke was sponsored oh
dang it yeah we are doing a sponsored
video on the crew channel that's going
to come out in like what two or three
weeks or something like that
two weeks is it two and a half because
there's been so much
falcon drama so far i mean i don't know
if this video is
ever gonna fly off the ground dude i
don't know if it's ever gonna soar dude
there's been so much falcon drama who
knew dude that there could be so much
drama okay so first off
i mean the drama is not related to our
context
kind of no um no so first off we we
you know we've had this uh deal in the
works for a while we're gonna put it on
a drone and do like a star wars thing
we're like and
then we got the idea of putting it on a
bird of prey i was like
that's kind of no one's ever done like
but that's the thing
we've seen gopros on like eagles and
hawks before
but i was like i've never seen a camera
on a peregrine falcon before the world's
fastest animal
let let alone like have a good quality
camera
that's the one that dives at like a
bajillion miles an hour 250 miles an
hour
yeah wow 240 miles an hour is the listed
top speed
really yeah yeah i thought it was like a
hundred and twenty
no that's that's the that's the that's
how fast people fall
birds are more aerodynamic than people
so they go fast wait
just hold on plow right into the ground
to get the worm
this bird this bird can dive at 240
miles an hour
yes yeah i gotta i i need a second
i gotta see this yeah from first person
with a camera attached to it well that's
the thing so that's that that we
were like man this is such a great idea
if we could put this on a peregrine
falcon that'd be amazing
so uh we threw a callout to action on
twitter and got a hold of uh
this woman named uh maya higa who
is a big time influencer uh really big
in the whole
um in uh ecological uh preservation
uh space uh she just started this
foundation raised a bunch of money for
it
like really impressive stuff for someone
who's like 22 years old she's ryan
higa's cousin i believe
no no no no no i'm serious i'm serious i
thought she was
i don't know i could i could totally be
wrong i totally totally be wrong i
apologize if i'm wrong
maybe there is i mean uh ryan's hawaiian
i don't know if she's hawaiian or not
but
let me just look i think she is
christian's on it christian's on it they
do share the last same name
um the same last name
so you guys were going to fly out to
what texas so she lives in texas now uh
she has this falcon that she rescued
last november
uh named i think his name is orion and
uh
she's been she rescued him she's been
rehabilitating him
and we reached out to her and uh we
started working
um on basically details to
make this video together and she has
this master falconer who is her
uh what do you call it what do you call
that role
christian um uh sponsor
um according to film i feed dot com
slash wiki maya dash five
she is a cousin of ryan higa all right
all right
yeah so she's a twitch streamer uh she
has a youtube channel
uh there's a bunch of stuff very popular
in her own right i didn't realize they
were cousins
and just a talent a family of talent i
honestly thought you just
said that as a joke because they share
the same last name so i was like
okay come on we gotta actually look that
up first um
yeah and so we're gonna fly out to texas
and uh work with her master falconer who
has uh some other falcons that are
trained
to hunt and we're like oh yeah this like
for the first time ever we actually have
a camera that is small
enough and lightweight enough that we
can mount it to the back of a falcon
and uh falcons have this thing uh where
you can put up to 10
of the weight of the bird on their on
their body
and so a falcon weighs approximately
half kilo 500 grams
and this camera is 26 grams once you
include another four or five grams for
the mount and all that stuff it comes
out to 30 grams which is less than the
of 500 which is 50.
big deal you can't put a gopro in a
falcon they're too heavy
so yeah um i mean you can get a naked
gopro which is just a stripped down bare
bones version of a gopro that's
lightweight enough but it's
it's cumbersome because it's a big it's
like a flying credit card that's not
aerodynamic you can't put that on the
falcon come on
so that was our date we're gonna put
this on the fastest animal in the world
uh through a number of circumstances our
first
uh trip got out there got canceled and
then our second trip we were actually
supposed to leave for texas today
we're supposed to be in texas right now
um yeah
but that trip ended up getting canceled
again uh
uh due to basically the master falconer
wasn't okay with the size of this camera
on the back of that falcon wait you just
said that could go on the back of a
falcon no problem yeah
the weight wasn't the issue he was
saying the profile of it the drag
of it because it has to face sideways
here he didn't like the
aerodynamics of it and he wasn't
comfortable with uh
the risk it would put his birds at when
they start stooping which is like a like
a dive i think
and uh so he just wasn't really
comfortable with doing that so we're
like okay
no big deal fortunately maya has friends
out here in
california that were willing to work
with us on this so we are now working
with them
and uh we we had a conversation with
them a couple times uh they seem really
cool they have a whole foundation out
here uh
i'm gonna be learning so much about
birds of prey and falcons
in about a week when we go up there to
shoot this i'm very excited
that's really awesome i'm really excited
for you guys i remember when i was in uh
elementary school we got taken to
a nature center and there was a falconer
there that had
uh a peregrine falcons and i know
they're not as big as eagles and stuff
no they're just
relatively small yeah but i just
remember being
a kid and seeing one of those things and
just seeing it up close you know
with its eyes and like its feathers and
its color patterns and just the
intensity of it
uh-huh it's just it's like being next to
a dinosaur
you know there's so they're such intense
creatures
i mean they're raptors yeah yeah i'm i'm
definitely looking forward to doing this
uh so one of the things i started
learning about
so it's been a whole process i don't
know how much of this process is going
to make it into the final video but i
had to basically design a mount
to put the camera on the back of a bird
and they sell these backpacks from
marshall radio
laboratories or i think that's the name
of them falcon yeah falcon backpacks
it's basically just a tiny little piece
of plastic
sleeping bags
and so what i ended up doing is i took
one of the the mounts that come with
this camera and i was gonna glue it to
the back of this we ended up just buying
our own backpack uh falcon backpack it's
a thing you can buy
and so i was gonna glue it to the back
of that and we're gonna ship it out to
them so that they could put it on
or just actually no originally we're
just gonna bring it with us and then
when it comes time to shoot we're gonna
put them on
what we learned is that they don't take
these backpacks off
what almost ever are they like fused no
they take them off every two years
what whoa wow yeah don't they get all
sweaty in there
i i mean i don't i don't i don't think
birds sweat uh but
so it's a thing you don't want to touch
these birds much they can get distressed
easily
and so you you kind of just don't really
do much of that so you only do it when
you have to so every couple years they
change out the backpacks
and that is yeah so basically
fun fact i had to come up with a new way
to mount this thing to the back of a
bird i was like okay so they have we we
came up the spring system
um and so a spring system
it's a spring system that clips into the
backpack
so the backpack stays there and the
camera can be removed
minimized tamper already has a backpack
on it yes
okay yeah it's for the gps you can't fly
a one of these birds without a gps
unit there's so many laws and rules and
regulations
uh yeah they might get lost
back into the wild from whence they came
no i'm not kidding that's a thing and
that's
that's the concern dude i hate the
government regulating my falcons
and yeah and so i you know i was like
okay so
um but yeah so the downside to that is
that now the lens is like right up
against the back originally i had the
thing pointed out
like a dragon rider on the back of the
bird but that was not gonna work uh
ergonomically for the bird
because again the safety of the birds is
our primary consideration so
so where are you gonna put the camera
now it's just resting on the back of the
bird like this
uh okay sideways go sideways yeah facing
forward but sideways so you still think
that's going to get you like that i
think it'll still get some pretty sweet
footage yeah i'll have it tilted back a
little bit so you don't see nothing but
the bird
um nothing but the bird so how far away
are we able to wear a visor
and watch what the birds sing oh my god
how far away are you from having a dude
you could be the first human to fly the
bird
yeah things from the back of the wings
so you just press the button and the
bird's like ah okay it causes them to
swoop left you're like i'm flying the
bird
this sounds peta would be all over us
just for making that joke
um so uh what's your question
i'm wondering about the gps thing okay
so again i know very little about what
goes into falconry and all this stuff
but apparently it's like
yeah they have they they usually wear
two gps units two separate ones
and it's it's like you literally are not
allowed to train
and fly these types of birds without a
gps unit in case they do get released
into the wild
it's what i've come to learn is that
um like the bird space
is intense it's cut throat
uh yeah so something that i learned with
talking with uh
these people uh and yeah i i don't know
if i want to say their names just yet
um yeah is that there's uh you cannot
use native birds
commercially you can't use them to
advertise something
and again i can't remember the specific
details it's it's it's a weird thought
man come on a peregrine falcon
a kestrel they are native to uh north
america and so they cannot be used
commercially so
as soon as they realize that this was a
commercial video for because it's like
advertising this camera
wow uh they're like yeah that we can't
do they're kidding me
um it's like oh gosh and okay so i was
like okay fine
so be it this is such a good idea hold
up that what if we just
get rid of the brand integration what if
we just say this is not a brand video
we are no longer doing this as a brand
thing they are not going to pay us any
money
this video is a really cool idea what if
we do that like well you're technically
still making money by putting it on
youtube it's like oh no
you're right
she has a whole youtube channel it's a
great area apparently it's
it's uh varying levels of grayness
well okay this is i object i have just
to be
a certain level of educational value
in the video dude
it's anti-exploitative you don't want to
exploit the birds and that's the the
premise behind these
who's like 100 i totally get the idea
of like let's preserve the wildlife and
let's not
let's not uh yeah exploit them and
they're
the experts so they know what's up can
you tell
somebody that they can't do that though
you know can you tell somebody that they
can't make a video with like a
ball of eagles so here's how clearly
basically
what you thought your license and your
birds would be taken away
they're gonna take my birds away yeah no
that's what they said they're like
we i mean it's you know this is crazy
apparently there's a whole bunch of
falconers out there that are ready to
bite each other's ankles and are like if
you make one
step out of line you're gonna get
reported by another falconer
that's why i'm saying it's like there's
like apparently a whole bunch of like
again i do not know much about this
space i might be making stuff up
accidentally i do not intend to
my intention making this video when we
go up there is to learn as much about
all of this as possible
and to relay that to our audience as
much as best as possible so that's why
we're able to do it
yes interesting oh no no no no we are
not going to be using a peregrine falcon
yeah so that's the disappointment factor
there uh
but uh i forget the name the specific uh
species of falcon but there's asparagus
they have another uh they have another
falcon that is basically just as fast
it's a middle eastern
type bird and because it's not native to
north american
asparagus why don't we just fly
somewhere else then
well the peregrine do you want to go
overseas yeah
no i guess what i'm saying is because
we're able to use this other bird
now we can actually keep this as an
insta360 video
uh there's no regulations in place for
that that's why i'm just like this is a
little odd to me it's strange
so you can exploit one bird just not the
other bird yeah
that's what i that's my that's where i'm
going
okay i know you don't know a lot about
this face and i'm not trying to like
yeah they
tell me everything you know about
falcons okay so jake christian just
brought this up it's true
apparently for like movies and
commercials and stuff if they need to
have a certain type of bird like i
forget if it was a raven or a crow
uh that's nate that a certain type of
raven or crow
that's like native to america they take
this other bird
and dye it black and use them in these
movies
again i do not know if that means like
the crows from game of thrones are all
freaking dyed black or no actually
probably not because they filmed in
freaking
golf can i do a legal deep dive on this
ireland please yes
tell us about bird law man imagine
are they they are dude every building in
los angeles got retrofitted to be able
to withstand
earthquakes i thought you said a bird
smack
[Laughter]
i also don't understand i think we're
far too uneducated to judge this right
now
my initial gut of like well you can
exploit these birds but not these ones
is also very weird i mean do you think
it's like
for like do you think they have the same
laws
i mean jake doesn't really surprise you
that you're not allowed to exploit
american birds but immigrant birds are
free game
well basically yeah the system it seems
like
what if you own like a bear
dude this is a whole other type of make
sure it's a bad bear not a here bear
okay
cause there's there's people that own
bears you know like yeah and
and who wants to bear like russian
people there are people i mean joe penna
uh got in contact with the person who
owns a polar bear for why would you want
to own that dude
there's people who are grizzly bears my
dad knew a guy growing up that owned
a black bear that was in the beer that
was in the these beer
commercials yeah pretty cool
and it was like super chill um he used
to bring him to the drive-in theater and
it used to watch the movies sitting in
the back of his truck like with his
hands on the on the hood and like
sit up there and and watch the movies
but anyways
is this the truth for all animals no no
no it's just specifically
uh these i don't know how far it extends
if it's just
falcons or if it's just american birds
of prey or if it's just
american flying wildlife i'm not exactly
sure
at all these are questions i'm going to
ask these falconers
when i meet them dude i am so i'm i'm so
enraged at the animaniacs right now for
like exploiting pigeons
like they did for so many years in their
cartoon in their cartoons
yeah i will say after watching uh
tiger king or whatever it was like
anytime you see a youtube channel or
something like with big cats even if
it's like a sanctuary and like but
they're
anthropomorphizing the cat's like i'm
cuddling with my friend he's so glad i'm
home
it's just that it feels so weird yeah i
would never i would never own a wild
animal
but that's just uh it's interesting
microsoft
really good family friends like best
friends
live down in orange county and they for
like
30 years own two shoppers own two lions
really really like house lines like that
house lines
yeah like yeah they had ones they had a
big they had a big
lab dog and it was like best friends
with these lions and they would like
sleep on their bed
they were totally house trained just
like you said but like
we're lively they were chill-ass just
like huge lines dude and there's like
photos like
of them just over there and there's like
a lion on the ground just lying down
and just looking like a lion line around
a little pen like well they had space
look at that lion lying there
but like it was so crazy to me as a kid
i was like who are these lion people in
house
lions i want that like what like
remember that
it can be done who is it 20th century
fox that had the lion or is it
gm mgm and they're the logo with the the
lion roaring
have you seen the behind the scenes
photo of like the lion on the set and
like literally the filmmakers like
four feet away from this lion eventually
that lion ended up
i think killing one of them really
again i am i do not have my facts in
place here i'm
very well might be wrong but i thought
there's something about that so it's
like i mean same thing with uh
what's uh sigrid and roy siegfried yeah
yeah we've learned a lot about how to i
mean people used to mistreat
wild animals like horribly there's a
reason why regulations become
regulated right right yeah i get that
and i see that side of it i just
i don't understand it it seems so
perplexing and weird that like
my lawyer brain is all over it right now
but anyways
um so we're you so you're filming with a
middle eastern raptor
yes it's a falcon it's a falcon so
the main source of disappointment for me
comes down to the fact that we cannot
we can no longer use the title that i
fell in love with
yep because as youtubers you know we
usually try to think of uh if you want
your video to do well it helps to think
of
video ideas from a title and thumbnail
standpoint that's a bit of like a
youtuber pro tip there and so
when we came up with the the title we
put a camera on the world's fastest
animal i was like that is up
ooh that's an amazing title yeah and now
we can't use that title because we're
not using the world's fastest animal
which is apparently the world's second
fastest out i mean put a camera on
basically the world's fastest animal on
basis
[Music]
a fast animal of the world so we i don't
know what our title ended up being but
it'll probably be something along the
lines of like we put a camera on a
falcon which is still pretty cool the
thumbnail is going to be awesome
uh i'm just picturing like a falcon with
his wings out and you can see like the
camera on his back
um bam where was that yeah so uh
i don't know what type of falcon it is
it's a middle eastern descent falcon
um but they have all kinds of birds
there they have owls they have eagles
they have hawks they have vultures
and we're going to get to see all of
them and i cannot be more excited about
that i am so looking forward to this
trip
that's awesome when are you guys going
next week yeah next week yeah
but i have to make sure that so natalie
actually designed
and made this thing does this this is
it's not textured so
uh basically i had her mock up
a one-to-one scale version of the go
camera
including the weight this weighs the
exact same amount as this camera
so that we can send this up along with
the mount that i'm making
to these falconers ahead of time to give
the falcons
as much time with the weight shape and
ergonomics of the camera as possible so
that they can get more comfortable with
it
so that when it comes time to actually
shooting they're not like distressed we
need to do like a rocky style montage of
the falcons
yeah like training with them with the
camera punch zooms and stuff
on them training and trying to flap
their wings with it on and hopping
around in slow-mo
oh yeah soaring that's all yeah
and then
oh we're frozen oh we might
our video recording might be crashing i
don't know
you guys aren't frozen to me our digital
video yeah obs crashed
uh-oh i'm still rolling on my end what
does that mean
and these cameras are rolling too i mean
we need to restart the whole video
no no we got we got backups on these
cameras it's just a workflow thing to
make it
quicker so thanks to a computer problem
christian might have to work overtime
uh can you do this can you still do
switching christian
no it's done i feel like dobie is trying
to find other ways to infiltrate our
lives and now that we've switched over
partially to resolve he's pissed at us
right now
he is out for blood
wow yeah dude resin printers are really
cool
i've and the price point is crazy now
dude they're they're finally at a point
where they're actually affordable we had
the form 2 printer which was a resin
printer we had that like what four years
ago
and that was like a two or three
thousand dollar printer and they only
loaned it to us
yeah they asked for it back we had to
give it back and now they probably just
got like hundreds of them sitting around
uh and now the printer that we have
upstairs the ella goo or whatever
is like a 250 printer which is crazy
pretty crazy that is the only thing i
hate about printing is the
mess uh and
here i'll give you the other thing it's
so smooth this looks injection molded
dude
like she did stain it down so it's okay
it's gonna be a little smooth but not
everything of it like the lens part of
that thing don't
exclude oh i didn't do it did you just
pop it open
you sure i didn't get it apart okay good
that's fine good because
because it's glued yes okay i thought
you broke the glue for a moment oh okay
see that let me try to pull it apart
that's what i do all of natalie's work
i love how this looks like a little like
half or a little portal turret
it totally does look like a portal
turret or a little uh
what's it wall-e uh eve yeah
yeah the renderer all right what was
what was what were we talking about
literally just a moment ago
resin printers yeah so the resin printer
that we have there's like 250 bucks
the only thing i don't like about resin
printing is it's a mess
you have to you have all this goop and
what you don't use you have to put back
in the thing
and if you leave it out too long it
starts curing and it's like it's a bit
of thing
and then on top of that you have to like
rinse it with alcohol then you have to
bathe it in uv
light but uh lagoo also makes this other
product that literally allows you to
wash it in alcohol and then bathe it in
uv light
uh one after another so it helps
simplify the process traditionally with
3d printers you got like
you melt the little plastic and you just
like have this little head that goes and
lays stuff down
and that's like these days that's like
so little fuss that you can
pretty much print anything um yeah
it's great yeah it's pretty wild hey
nico
oh i'm getting singled out here nico
uh-oh
hey man i was just trying to blend into
the background
how can you kind of do with that shirt
and
slide guys are you there actually i only
see a head that looks like nico back
there
what what what's up jake
[Laughter]
um what are you working on man i want to
hear what you're working on too
we're working on some final like the end
of day checkups here with uh yeah
exactly
jake's like but seriously what are you
what are you doing yeah
we're not doing a podcast we're doing a
real work meeting now
i'm working on setting up a location for
this video we're doing on the corridor
channel
um which is going to be done in unreal
engine so you guys have been obviously
hearing us talk about unreal engine a
whole bunch
uh a lot of this is in prep for local
zero which is a show that was greenlit
on the site
um but did you say for the corridor
channel
yeah for the corridor channel that's
right
that's right guys our biggest channel
that gets the most views and the most
subscribers
every dustin off our channel our bread
winner
[Laughter]
which by the way i only started watching
our crew
and i didn't realize there was all these
videos that you guys have made
from all these years that i'd already
seen
that's my favorite comment to read it's
like wait you guys have another channel
what
wait you guys made these videos you guys
did the minecraft video
yeah i had this guy hit me up so the uh
dji just came out with a new fpv drone
and i posted a video to my personal
youtube channel first time in a very
long time
of just me flying through some trees and
i crashed that drone at the end of the
video
and so this reporter from the uk reached
out to me from
i forget the name of the in in
[Music]
and anyway um
[Laughter]
he uh reached out just to ask some
questions about it and to ask like who i
was and stuff like that and i told him
you know i'm from quarter we made this
video the boss dynamics video was like
oh
i wrote an article about that last year
uh
basically about that exact video he's
like oh i didn't know that you uh did
that
[Laughter]
so what's the plan here nico what's the
plan with this video
all right what's the point the plan with
this video is digital trends
is the name of the publication um so oh
screw it i'm just going to spoil the
video
a little bit here whatever all right i
mean it's not that groundbreaking
i've read the comments people love that
we spoil stuff for them
do they yeah i read the comments too i
showed them the names no there's always
like one or two comments that are like i
don't like that you guys talk about
the upcoming video before it's out and
i'm like i totally get that
but we're trying something i mean i mean
we're talking about that's what we're
doing you know yeah we're just talking
about what we're doing right now and
what we're doing is what's coming out on
sunday yeah yeah so uh not this though
we're talking about this the premise for
this video is that
um you know in a video game how i can
get shot a thousand times and your
character is fine not a big deal
yeah they don't cut to a cinematic and
like the bad guy points a gun at you and
your character's like whoa
don't shoot you know it's a big deal
like
i guess now this one bullet is now going
to kill them uh so this video is about
that where there's a
unstoppable dude that the goons can't
stop
until they get a camera pointed at him
and it enters a cinematic
and he's like wait what are you doing oh
no i'm in a cinematic like that's right
and then you find the main character
finds that his long-lost passion is
acting
um so
we uh i'm setting up an environment for
this um and it's basically it's a
pre-built environment from the unreal
store that's free it's this factory
environment but i'm going through and
just tweaking the lighting and the
settings and making it look a little
more cinematic and making the light look
nicer because
unreal has real-time race tracing which
is awesome because it's basically all
the exact same technology from mental
ray which is the renderer that i learned
back when i was
in my early 20s and late teens uh and
you know wait why is mental ray the
comparison and not something like octane
because uh something like octane these
days is basically what's called a path
tracing engine where
everything is a shooting rays out into
the scene
uh the camera shoots phrases out of the
scenes the lights shoot raise out into
the scenes
the scene shoots rays out into the
scenes like everything shoots rays
and it takes a long time to render well
it doesn't take that long to render it
takes some time to render um
but what you get out of it is a
perfectly accurate scene because there's
no
check boxes to check there's no settings
to fuzz
you either render it or you don't it's
just either photo real or it's not
yeah no it's either photo real or it's
not rendered exactly
uh everything acts like light is
supposed to do which is actually this is
this trend was started with something
called maxwell render back in the day
i remember experimenting with maxwell
renderer on uh
the lord of the rings video we did
because i was trying to render the blood
using maxwell but it was so slow
and i also didn't have a license for it
so i couldn't
just had a big watermark like on the
block yeah exactly the first runners
from maxwell renders
oh my god this looks so good why is that
like they're the first ones to be like
all right
lights you can't just put an object that
says it's light in the scene
that's not how lights work lights are
actually emitted from surfaces and
things that
that are glowing so if you're gonna have
a light in your scene you need like like
a soft boxes that we have in here it's
like
now if you want those to light up your
scene you actually have to build a model
that has
a texture that emits light or you know
have a light with like a lens shape to
project the light you actually have to
physically have a light in your scene
you can no longer just
have an imaginary light that's just
shining light but the light doesn't
exist because that's you don't get
photorealism with that
um and maxwell render was one of these
first things to have like texture based
lighting
where your everything that's in the
scene bounce creates light because at
the end of the day
a white wall that has light bouncing off
of it and a white
soft box that just turned down low are
doing the exact same thing was maxwell
an unbiased renderer
okay yeah cause technically like octane
and redshift are not
fully unbiased yeah but exactly for all
intents and purposes yeah yeah they are
yeah um so but before that
before that you had mental ray um
there's a couple other renders and
v-ray v-ray um render man
render man arnold brazil
wait wait what brazil that was a
renderer yep i used that one a bit too
brazil is really nice um so
mentoring on your sao paulo settings of
course
uh i think brazil's like the first one
to have like final gather built into it
and stuff
uh i could be i'm probably wrong i was
you know like 13 years old
but i was more like 15 years old it
doesn't matter those are only two years
apart
um it seemed like a long time back then
uh
anyways where i'm going with all this is
that with programs like mental ray
um your your scene was lit or rendered
using a combination of different
techniques so
like when you're playing a video game
you're not doing path tracing you're not
doing the full on light simulation
because it just takes too long to render
each frame so you have a lot of little
like
math shortcuts that get you close to the
same effect like for example
let's say you have a 3d sphere and you
have a
point that represents a light in your
scene well you know you can do path
tracing you shoot rays off that point
and to all 360 degrees well i guess
there's more than 360 degrees when
you're talking about three dimensions
but you know
you could have that point shooting rays
in every direction you could calculate
which h
rays hit the sphere where they bounce
what the value is etc
or you just take a measurement on the
surface of that sphere
measure how much that surface is pointed
at the light or pointed away from the
light and just apply that to a black and
white scale a gradient
you know so that's that's the shortcut
and those kind of rendering shortcuts
are what's happening
in video games that's what happened in
old render engines and so mental ray
was kind of one of these engines that
straddled both worlds where you had
all these like rendering shortcuts the
basic math versions of rendering and
then you had the initial
like ray tracing where you know lights
shoot rays and those rays bounce off
things that reflect and there was ray
tracing engines in the 90s too
but then there's also things like final
gather and you know global illumination
ambient occlusion which represents how
you know light bounces off surface
surfaces and lights up shadows you had
area lights lights that didn't have to
just be a point but could have
size and therefore they would influence
the softness of the shadow
and all these kind of different things
that started stepping towards that
realistic
photorealistic you know world of
rendering but it wasn't quite
photorealistic because you had to guess
where the balance was between your ray
traced stuff and your global
illumination stuff and then like the
old-fashioned
rendering hacks that you'd use to like
you know get your shadow maps to look a
certain way or get your services to look
a certain way
i'm sorry i'm just like our poor
audience right now
we like this podcast we have talked
we've gotten really deep into the weeds
of render engines
of falcon drama of
anime like anime scale
yeah and now i'm talking about render
engines
anyways so the thing i'm just gonna keep
going so you guys just hold on no i'm
super down
i love this so the thing is you know
when you're shooting out rays
like from lights and you don't want to
measure you know what the rays hit what
the surfaces they hit you know what the
shadows are like
you need to cast a lot of rays to
eventually average out
the results you're getting to not have
an image it's all grainy and noisy
uh you need to shoot thousands and
thousands of rays to eventually just you
know
have covered every single pixel many
many times over and have everything
averaged out and be smooth
uh and nvidia was like
what if we just trained an ai on that
specific noise pattern to denoise it
like what if we just rendered a shot of
a scene with all the samples turned up
all the way and what if we rendered that
same shot with all the samples turned
down
all the way and we just taught an ai to
make the two look the same
which is an actual super approachable
way to train an ai so they came out with
a denoising system
for ray tracing where you could do a
lower sampled ray tracing scene
and denoise it using ai and have it look
like it's a higher sampled version
yeah make it look all smooth and exact
and crispy
and yep so this is what you have in real
time ray tracing in video games these
days
um plus the fact that the cards
themselves are getting fast enough they
can actually shoot out of
considerable number of rays in real time
even without the denoising the denoiser
yeah extra perk on top of that yeah so
much of this has been
only possible because of the new line of
gpus starting with the the
2000 series another 3000 series the
architecture of those cards are
specifically geared towards being able
to shoot out tons of rays really quickly
and annoy them i guess um whereas like
the
the previous line like the 1080 the 980
and
down uh below that they were you know
very good graphics cards for the time
but they couldn't handle this
type of calculation yeah all the the
hardware on those cards are made fast
enough
they're made for the math of doing those
you know those old-fashioned hacks for
rendering to doing that quickly as
opposed to shooting out rays and doing
the geometry of rays quickly um
but what's really cool is that all this
real-time ray tracing it's basically the
exact
same settings as when i build a scene in
mental ray when i was like 15 years old
except now it's just all happening in
real time so i've gotten to see
that jump in graphics so it's not like a
new technique it's not like well we're
you know we figured out a new type of
math to represent light and it's faster
like you know that stuff happens all the
time
not necessarily in terms of life but in
terms like computer science you know the
math behind like
optics and rendering hasn't exactly
changed that much in the last
like 20 30 years it's all like in it's
it was for the longest time just
theory but like we know how light works
is basically just geometry
yeah exactly so we reached the point
finally where
the math that i was doing back then can
happen in real time
more or less the exact same way it was
happening back then but it can happen at
frames per second now on my computer
that's pretty crazy which is crazy so
now i can build these scenes and just
like
oh that's too bright let's move the
light over there let me move this here
oh that looks pretty let me move this oh
that looks really nice let me move the
camera here oh that's extra shiny i like
that like
i can't i couldn't do that back then you
know you'd render it and you'd guess and
you're like okay that looks nice
well i guess i'll commit to this one
because to find another angle is gonna
take me two hours
i yeah i hated mental ray
i hated it so much that i did not get
into 3d rendering until octane came out
yeah it sucked do you have to like find
so many like you have to check this box
you have to flip this
it was overwhelming setting like because
it was like you want anyone who's
getting into like 3d rendering they want
to make their stuff look realistic they
want to make it look as real as possible
but with mental ray you know it's it's
just a whole giant list of check box
check marks and like sliders and stuff
just to kind of like
ride the line between making something
look realistic and not take a million
years to render
but also like some of those things you
don't know what they they did or what
like it was so confusing for someone
who's just getting the 3d rendering that
is so overwhelming
and that is why i think we're seeing so
many artists getting into 3d rendering
now is because octane
and and others like you know arnold
redshift
like you're saying it's like it's just
on you like you throw
you you make a scene you throw it on a
texture you drop in a light
you hit on and then it just
looks amazing yeah where's the on button
yeah yeah which is great because i think
that's one reason i was able to pick up
octane so much better yeah
now in unreal this you know the
real-time retracing stuff is kind of
like mental ray where it's back to
sliders and check boxes
now we know the real reason why i chose
to learn houdini i mean you just gave us
the
recipe to crypto right there basically
exactly so yeah you know for me it's
like going back to like an old friend
it's like oh i'm so familiar with all
this like
i'm fast i'm quick i can make it look
good like
i've picked up unreal engine which i'm
not very good at but suddenly i'm
pumping out cool renders and then he was
like whoa nico a nice job i'm like yeah
thanks because the thing is like
i'm having a little a mild crisey here
where it's like
everyone's using blender and cinema 4d
these days i'm not very good with cinema
4d i
know very little about blender i learned
in 3ds max
and at this point like when i want to do
simple things that don't really
need a specific program i'm finding
myself yearning for just getting 3ds max
installed again just
like oh i gotta do a quick little model
of something it's like i can do that in
3ds max
instantly whereas i can sit there
because it's like
in the closet with 3ds max
desktop just he's like ivy opens the
door and you're like oh this is so
awkward
smacks i'm so sorry close the door don't
tell anybody
if you want to max out you can well the
reason we set the weight in 3ds max is
the same reason we're stepping away from
adobe right now which is like
you know the parent umbrella company
gets so big that they stop focusing on
like making these programs stable for
the people who are making a living off
of them
and they become like half-assed
half-baked buggy things and it's like
well
gee thanks for thanks thanks for
breaking my project or thanks for like i
had a deadline yes tomorrow i was gonna
hit and thanks for making it below that
you know i'm paying you guys for these
things like sorry
this is a rant it's not really focused
on 3ds max it's still focused on adobe
you know it's just one of those things
where it's like 3ds max would crash on
me
all the time and at a certain point i
was over it and i wanted to learn
something else and i wasn't doing a ton
of 3d work anymore
um you know so it's like let's jump wait
you made the jump to cinema 4d but who
knows maybe 3ds max is good these days
maybe not i haven't barely changed i
looked into it recently it's got some
new features naturally but it's like
it's still
roughly the same yeah whereas cinema 4d
on the other hand comes out with
pretty banging features every year yeah
like that you could feel that there was
development in cinema
yeah and yeah for me the thing that
really pushed me over was just like
all of these artists that i was
following on instagram like the
community
they're all like oh yeah cinema4d it's
great the tutorials were all there it's
like it
was like okay i feel like i'll have some
help if i jump into this the only reason
why
i learned 3ds max back in the day was
because you and sam
knew 3ds max that was like literally the
only reason why i chose it well
3ds max back then was you know was to
artists like us what cinema 4d is now to
artists
that is true yeah yeah we're talking
about eight years community supported
3d pack 3d software out there um it's
really accessible it's really
approachable in terms of like how things
are laid out like
you know mentally you can figure things
out um it was free
ish you can download the student version
[Laughter]
it was very easy to pirate too i never
had to i was always able to just get the
the
the student version because they don't
actually verify if you're a student
you're just like i'm a student you're
like cool here you go
[Music]
students i signed my student id i did
that for the longest time going to
movies
like oh yeah i graduated two years ago
but i'm a student
i remember doing that too yeah so
needless to say these days you know
working unreal
uh with ray tracing is wonderful there's
still the quirks of like how do you get
that clean
image because one of the funny things is
unreal yeah
in real when you render because back in
the day when you see like toy story
um you know it's like it looks amazing
the 3d animation is so clean
those toys are so close his room's so
tidy
no mess anywhere um so
one of the things that pixar talked
about that was important to them back
then is that
they didn't want to have any aliasing no
flickering whatsoever in like not a
single pixel could flicker in their
shots they had to be
rock solid and they're using render man
back then and one of the things that
render man did is that didn't use
polygons it used nurbs oh
okay yeah so like you know rather than
defining something with like
points you know like i'm going to define
three points and within those three
points i have a polygon aka a triangle
um rather than doing that they basically
would have mathematically defined
curves and then the computer would
subdivide those curves
into surfaces as needed depending on how
close or far they were from the camera
so you didn't have polygons you just had
a procedurally generated surface based
on the curves that you defined for your
characters
for you math nerds out there it's the
difference between a summation and an
integral yeah math nerds all right so i
think the summary here is that niko's
going back to 3ds max
for all programs uh he's just going to
try to do everything out of 3ds max
including edit
i do hear you though about the
hesitation of like you because
for the last two years i didn't really
use cinema 4d that much
like i would use it for a project here
and there like especially through boston
and whatnot
but uh clint was always like so into
cinema 4d that any time we had some sort
of rendering need
he was able to just just take it you
know he was able to just do it and so as
a result
i ended up my cinema 4d skills started
atrophying
and i felt like i feel like i can relate
to here it's like you kind of feel like
a lack of confidence in opening the
program to do something because like i
don't remember where the button is
i don't remember the shortcut for that
guys we do not not do things because
they are hard
in this decade in this decade
all right uh the guitar is here the
guitars arrived
hold up let me let me fix like
finish i just started uh
literally it was just like okay i just
opened the program i just started trying
to make something stupid and
like i just did that a few times and it
was surprisingly quick for it to come
back
like pretty quick yeah i promised myself
gaps in my knowledge when i started
learning some cinema 4d
yeah you made that really awesome like
heart render
last year using all the basic techniques
that i learned it worked
it worked guys don't be afraid to learn
nico don't be afraid to learn
all the children singing chorus now
don't be afraid to learn
questions learning how to make a movie i
was learning blender
oh that's right but then i made a movie
instead
it's like that song because i got high
you know it's like i was gonna learn
blender
but then i made a movie it's just like
no blender is very approachable for a 3d
noob like me
definitely recommend it um
3ds max jake let's let's play a song
together yeah
it's song time okay all right it's song
and time are we sorry
what's all right i'm gonna play
uh d
uh d minor seven and c major back and
forth okay
wait i gotta i gotta get these lyrics
out okay
okay i'm gonna i'm just gonna do a
little
we choose to go to the moon in this
decade
and do the other things not because they
are easy
but because they are hard because that
goal will serve to organize and measure
the best of our
energies and skills because that
challenge is the one that we are willing
to accept
one that we are unwilling to postpone
and one which we intend to win
and the others too
[Music]
that's the lesson of the podcast today
guys
thanks for listening consider
subscribing
[Music]
all right i'm gonna scream into the
microphone
in five four
two
one